it seems like there's this sort of  default thing now for women and maybe  for men as well but for women of just  it's like being hot is the only  the only girl I just I just want to be  sexy and I don't I don't think that was  the case years ago back in the 90s I  mean I don't know whether you can attest  to this but um it seemed it seemed like  you know there were some girls who were  oh she's she's more of a bookish kind of  intellectual or there's another one and  she wants to do it yeah be an artist and  now it seems like and I'm not saying for  everybody because obviously you can't  generalize but it does seem like the  currency now is she you know am I hot  how many followers have I got on  Instagram it's that seems to be the main